ce dimanche 16 juillet le Manoir De La
Possonnière à couture sur Loire en
Loir-et-Cher rassemble deux géants de la
Renaissance dans un dialogue jouéchanté
Léonard de Vinci l'ingénieur est peintre
d'un côté et Nicolas macave elle le
stratège politique de l'autre je crois
que nous pouvons dire vous et moi que la
fortune nous a sauvé jusqu'à maintenant
en effet
inspiré de faits historiques le
spectacle de la compagnie en EOS relate
les rencontres entre les deux penseurs
italiens du 15e siècle ils se sont
rencontrés alors un peu étonnamment ni
Leonard ni Machiavel n’en parle
peut-être parce que ça se tout ça se
cloue je veux pas en dire trop mais
quand même sur une forme d'échec alors
est-ce que c'est pour ça mais on a
beaucoup de traces qui nous montrent
qu'ils se sont rencontrés ils ont signé
des contrats ensemble etc les arts la
guerre la politique les sciences le
spectacle revient sur les thèmes favoris
des deux savants présentés dans la
littérature populaire comme deux génies
barbus pour Léonard de Vinci ici le
contrepied est total celui qui vécu les
trois dernières années de sa vie à
Amboise est jeune et humble
j'ai mis le grec ni le latin et encore
moins à l'université dans l'histoire
historique Léonard est plus âgé que
Machiavel d'au moins une trentaine
d'années et là ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est exactement le contraire en fait du
coup on a pris le parti de s'échapper du
cliché de Léonard et d'autre part dans
d'en faire quelqu'un de d'un peu fou fou
en tout cas de traverser par des idées
en permanence presque un obsessionnel
quoi les costumes et les décors sont de
deux artistes loir-et-chariens Jurgen
400 Gruber et Frédéric Clerc les
musiques Renaissance elles nous
transporte au 16e siècle Léonard et
Machiavel rencontre de deux génies ce
dimanche à partir de 16h30 précédé d'une
conférence réservation sur le site
internet et l'oiseau les rendez-vous de
la Possonnière tarif 25 euros